I love this next one. This is just the good
old fashioned political dressing down. Now
in general, it's really common that when presidents
go to sporting events, it's sort of a smattering
of cheers and boos and very frequently there
are booze, no matter who the president
does, no matter what their approval rating
happens to be at the time. And part of that
is there's a lot of people who just want to
see sports. They don't want presidents there
at all. They don't want it made political
in any sense. And that's a common thing that
takes place at sporting events. Donald Trump
over the weekend went to the fifth game of
the major league baseball world series, played
in Washington D C and he was not only met
with rezoning booze but also chance of lock
him up. Donald Trump showed up with a whole
cast of characters and criminals, including
Senator Lindsey Graham, that totally disgusting.
Congressman Kevin McCarthy, vile Republican,
Matt Gates and a whole bunch of others and
there was a lot, a lot, a lot of booing. Take
a look
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and then the chance of lock him up, break
out
[inaudible]
here's another recording of the lock them
up chance and it is just a, it's, it's like
a beautiful symphony on a uh, chilly fall
morning in Boston as you observed the foliage,
just hearing this
[inaudible]
it's also hilarious that Donald Trump was
asked to and declined to toss out the first
pitch. I think we know why Donald Trump can't
throw. It would have been an incredible embarrassment
to his suppose at alpha male status if you
went out there and threw out a first pitch
instead chef Jose on to this throughout the
first pitch and he is a big, big critic of
Donald Trump and it was a funny to see him
do that as well. Now, a genuine question here.
Barron Trump is 13 years old today. I mean,
it's not his birthday today as of today, he's
13 years old. I have no idea if Baron Trump
likes baseball. But you see your dad take
Lindsay Graham to the world series instead
of you. That seems a little odd to me. I don't
know what's going on there. One of the notable
things is that Donald Trump actually looks
visibly shocked that he's being booed by the
entire stadium.
And this gets to something I've been wanting
to talk about for a while. Donald Trump truly
seems to believe that the echo chamber in
which he lives of Twitter blocking anybody,
he doesn't like golf courses where everybody
is just, you know, Brown nosing rallies with
handpicked sycophants. He seems to really
believe that's America. He seems to think
that is the, the mood of the country. And
that's why he believes any poll that shows
he has a 55 or 60% disapproval rating must
be fake news. Suddenly he shows up in front
of a crowd that was not handpicked for him
and it's a veritable disaster. You can visibly
see when Donald Trump realized that the booze
and the chance of lock him up our for him
and he tightens up and he becomes like a different
person. Now, there's another funny thing about
this. The anti Obama, right throughout Barack
Obama's presidency thought that everybody
felt like that crowd about Barack Obama.
They thought everybody hates this guy. Obama
left office with a 59% approval on the last
day in office, an approval rating. Donald
Trump has not even come close to having at
any point during the nearly three years that
he's been in office. Trump literally cannot
go out in public if it's actual public, not
one of these curated audience at a rally.
Uh, he can't go out in public without being
despised and booed. I saw a funny comment
online. It was something like, Hey listen.
Some people were booing and some people were
cheering. What you think of Donald Trump determines
whether you heard the cheers or the booze.
This sort of, it's all equal. It's all perception.
That's all it is. Very postmodern by the way
of some defenders of Trump. That's not how
sound works. Some people were cheering. You
can't hear them. Over many of those boos.
This is like that Simpsons episode. I haven't
watched the Simpsons in so long, but some
episodes really made an impression on me.
There's an episode where Mr. Burns kind of
like the, you know, old rich, conservative
white dude equivalent. He's getting booed
somewhere in public and he asks, uh, are they
booing me? No, no, no sir. They're saying
Booher burns, burns. They're cheering for
you, Mr. Burns. Very good. Thank you. Here
it is. One more time. There are military service
members on the big screen. People are cheering
for them. The second the screen flips to Trump,
the booing explodes.
[inaudible] quite
a day. Really, truly delightful. Uh, why does
he even do that? I, I, my biggest complaint
about all of this is come on, you're, you're
supposedly the alpha male. Throw out that
first pitch. I would love to see that there
have been bad first pitches and people have
survived. Um, uh, Gary Del Bhate, Howard Stern's
producer, he had a doozy where I think he
hit an umpire in the back of the head about
30 feet off, center off the center line. Just
pitched that first pitch. I w Bush did it.
Obama did it. John Kerry was even photograph
throwing footballs or catching footballs.
Just do it. Donald Trump, I would love to
see it. A delightful, uh, uh, event fun for
the entire family.